hi I'm Timmy the trashcan and I love
trash
they all taste so good instead of
throwing your trash on the floor won't
you please give it to me thank you for
considering your fellow patrons so we
are live here from the Maryland Holiday
Inn in Timonium Maryland a rest stop
essentially a truck stop where they have
it's like a woman described it to me she
goes it's like a rest stop that they
built a town around that's kind of the
vibe here I'm playing at Magoo B's
comedy club all weekend and staying in
the Holiday Inn and I figured I would
release this episode we were gonna re
release an old episode and then just
stuff ads in that and you know something
you people haven't heard and but one of
the reasons I'm not more successful is I
don't have other contempt for my fanbase
I'm trying to acquire that that is such
an ingredient to success you look at the
people that are really successful and
they they they walk off stage and you
can tell they're disgusted by the people
that they just had to entertain and I
don't really feel that way so I try to
like do the right thing by you people
which will lead me down a road to
poverty because like it just doesn't
it's you I need to just literally bash
you over the head every chance I get
robbed you you know if I was a tow truck
guy I would shoot your tires out and
then you know drive by pretend I didn't
see you be like oh would you have a
problem here
that's what successful people do so I'm
learning how to do that I'm trying to do
that but I'm staying the beautiful
Holiday Inn which is what what do you
think it is you know towels it when you
use them to wash your face take a layer
of skin off your face you know so
industrial soap like if you've ever felt
like
I would imagine prison soap feels like
I've never been to prison I've never
really been to jail
because I'm white I should have gone
many many times but I have not but I
imagine that prison shop has a feel like
the Holiday Inn Shop where it smells
like so like they've done nothing to
disguise the smell of soap like it's not
there's no lavender there's nothing in
it that makes you feel it's soap it's
straight-up
old-school hand soap that you would use
after painting class in kindergarten in
the 90s when they didn't know any better
and they were just like yeah wash your
hands with this we also wash the floor
with it that's what Holiday Inns are
using to say you can wash yourself just
industrial-strength ammonia Laden soap
and it's nice and then you look around
Baltimore you let you take it out of
here should I spend more money on a
hotel why why they get shot in a better
area of town to get shot walking to a
nicer hotel it doesn't matter the area
has a lot of problems you know I'm not
even in Baltimore I'm 20 minutes out 25
minutes out in Timonium which sounds
like ammonia like it the name of the
place sounds like a chemical that they
found like a toxic chemical that they
found a company dumping in a river
that's what it sounds like it's like oh
yeah well the babies were born with real
real issues because they were dumped in
Timonium and that river for so long and
nobody knew that's what it feels like
and then you look at the people you're
like yeah that may be what it is because
it's got a real interesting feel here
what did you say Josh josh is a local
comic he's he's helping me record this
podcast what did you say another comic
said about these people we won't say who
the comic is but he said he's like I
feel like I'm performing for people that
work at Home Depot and I was like no no
you're performing for people that aspire
to work at home deep yeah it's yeah this
is they would love to have that orange
apron and be like yeah yeah I did it
it's a it's a rough road
out here it just seems to be you know
cuz they're they're kind of well outside
the realm of that defense industrial
complex Mario yeah they want that that
you know what I performed at the
Bethesda Maryland Country Club for you
know people that were literally dripping
in blood it was a very different vibe
you know when you drove through Bethesda
Maryland you're driving you're looking
at these beautiful English Tudor style
homes these brick castles stone castles
set back far from the road really nice
and then and you're like oh this is all
built with blood money all of it you
know but this area you're like man this
could use some blood money
this could really use something like
these people were disappointed when they
they couldn't go to Iran I think half of
these people were excited as [ __ ] about
the draft they were like I'm psyched I
get to go to Tehran and maybe get killed
[ __ ] yeah
they're Deron's pretty nice yeah they
were so happy and then that we averted
war and they were so upset and they're
just [ __ ] they're like [ __ ] I was so
glad so many of my friend nobody really
wants to admit this we need we need like
six wars right now with the amount of
people we have selling CBD oil we need
war a lot of war and I mean this is
unpopular to say people won't like this
I'm against war as like in the sense and
I'm principled and I don't want people
to die however however let's look at the
numbers we got to get rid of you a few
of my friends need to go to the desert
and get shot that's the way it is and
that's an uncomfortable thing to say
especially to them and I've said this to
them and when they've asked me for
advice I'm like the reality is you need
to get shot in the desert because with
so many people that I know the best
version of them is a flag on a mantle
like they're just dead and they can
inspire future generations of people
yeah I remember going over to my
grandfather's house they just point to a
flag on the mantel and go uncle Jerrod
gave it all
there's a little kid you just kind of
remember that it makes an impact on you
it's so mu now we're gonna be like uncle
gerard sells CBD it's much better than
he's a hero who knows what he did
they're probably committed rampant
sexual assault and then [ __ ] got
killed and friendly fire but it doesn't
matter it doesn't matter that he killed
himself or he his friend shot him in the
night cuz he who knows it's it's joke
yeah you still get a flag you still
inspired generations of people that are
and that's the thing that nobody wants
to talk about nobody wants to admit that
we we need a war we need a war or we
need to shave some numbers off we've got
too many people wandering around that
really have no clue as to what they're
gonna do and there's people listening to
this show right now that say I'm one of
those people and the reality is I'm
saying to you very nicely and very
reasonably the best thing you can do the
best thing you can do for your friends
and your family is go get killed in Iraq
or Afghanistan or Iran don't go by the
way don't go and then come back with
PTSD and get a pit bull and be homeless
instead of pretend and then I'm supposed
to contribute from it I don't want that
either we're not looking we're not
looking for that what we're looking for
is you gotta go and you got to not come
back that's your reality a lot of my
friends you will have to go and not come
back where you come back as a flag
that's what that's what you come back at
ya you come back as a flag you come back
as somebody that's you know or you just
come back and you're happy and it's fine
I'm not trying to deal with people that
are like scarred my friend was a marine
he went there
probably killed a bunch of people and
he's really a nice guy he's fine and
he's a cool dude and I I'm not into the
flashbacks and the like dark persona and
I'm not saying it's not needed but just
it is what it is you know what we're
doing over there there's nobody that
should join the military now and shocked
about what it really is you know what it
really is you know you're not handing
out
Kandee to the townspeople it is what it
is you're putting a gun in a toddler's
face and saying where's daddy you know
what it is and you're gonna do that yet
no hate for me but just don't come back
all shocked that would be the SD because
it wasn't what you thought you thought
you were gonna be to helping people in
Iraq find their lost dogs I'm just
picturing you as a recruiter like a
daddy recruiter in a high school just
yelling at 17-year old I'd recruit a lot
more people because I'd be honest I'd be
like who wants to shoot up this school
do you want to shoot form a line how
let's go he just put you keep that
thought hold that thought
can on a plane you know where else their
schools we're gonna really be on a plane
and we're just gonna have you shoot up
other schools there's bullies there too
they won't like you either see I like
that you're taking their talents and
then guiding it somewhere else yeah I
mean listen at the end of the day I know
that there's a lot of heroic people in
the military that have great people that
are doing something that I do not have
the balls to do and that's great but
then there's also a lot of my personal
friends that need to get killed and are
living in safe areas and they're never
gonna be killed and because they live in
the suburbs they're never gonna be
caught in the crossfire of a bad drug
deal for the most part at least not for
a few years till things really start
heating up out there but for right now
it's just bacon egg and cheese and and
and nothing so what they need is to be
heroes all of my friends need to be
heroes that's all and who's to say what
a hero is I mean you know one guy's hero
is another person's you literally shot
my baby so I don't I'm not saying what
it is I just know that you're joining
the military now understand what it is
right and a lot of it is good listen
we've done a lot of great things at the
military we've done a lot of
not-so-great things I don't know which
one of them you're gonna do and neither
do you
that's the fun of it you don't really
know which which end you're gonna be on
you could get there and go well there
this doesn't seem great but you're in
now and it is what it is you know I
thought comedy
is gonna be different it's eight it's
not but you know it's not like PTSD
where I'm like being like [ __ ] I thought
it was gonna be you know I'm you know
yeah I'm not gonna hang myself I'm not
gonna you know yet if I do I'll do it
quietly you know yeah
and I do think we should provide better
mental health care for the soldiers that
come back but I also think a way to
avoid some of it is to be very honest
about kind of what it might be like we
might be like you might be helping
people and killing terrorists you also
might be the terrorist we don't know yet
we don't know which mission you're gonna
be on if we don't know no kind of makes
it fun yes your honor that's what makes
it fun so just understood but the the
larger point here is that that so many
people in this country need to be heroes
and they we need to give them a way for
them to be heroes and if they continue
along their path of not getting shot in
a foreign country it will help no one so
that's just my point so I'm telling all
my friends baby it's time to enlist I
don't know maybe it's not but at the end
of the day it's something to think hey
it's something to think about I just
moved I just moved I got a new apartment
I'm I'm in the Hollywood Hills but I'm
not up in the Hills Hills I'm I'm on
like a hill on the way to the hills it
it's nice it's fine and and the parking
situation is very very bad there and
they they tow I don't know if you guys
you've ever been in area where they tow
people all the time they just tow and
and and one of and the reason I think
that they tell people all the time on
this block is because this is a block of
predominantly apartments and people that
live in apartment and specifically nice
apartments like condos or as they call
them on my block villas they're
certainly not villas but they call them
villas what a rebrand people get people
that live in villas are are are rats
like they'll pick up the
Caldecott people that live in big
estates and mansions don't they're not
paying attention they're barely home
they're relying on their staff to really
inform on the poor [ __ ] who parked his
car where he shouldn't have but people
in a pretend villa or a high-end
apartment that they can't afford a house
and maybe they don't have it because
they don't have any children and they're
just angry they're angry because they're
above the people that don't have the
money to live in the villa but they're
far below the people who live in an
actual home with an actual family and
have a net so these people pick up the
phone every chance they get to call the
management company or the police they
are rats this is they're just angry
they'll do it then and I could see them
they look through their little windows
with their beady eyes or a little mirror
do Wells and they you know they probably
you know they make a decent income
compared it to [ __ ] Timonium but
compared to LA they're constantly in the
shadow of real wealth and it makes them
angry literally in the shadow literally
in the shadows it houses on the hills
that literally just look look down on
them people in Maseratis cutting them
off every day fifteen year old with
YouTube channels grossing more money
than they'll see in their life you know
hot chicks just walking around taking
selfies you know selling their [ __ ] on
the street for millions of dollars and
these people and villas these stupid
little villas just waiting to call the
cops on somebody because it's 7:01 and
it's time to tow this [ __ ] car and
they they I'm sure they look out their
window and enjoy it they enjoy it they
enjoy watching it get towed they like it
they like rules is that they're only
ownership they're just like that's my
parking lot at the villa yeah I think
they just are in love with rules because
the the middle like people that get to
the villa level in life or
rule-followers for the most part and you
know unless they started at zero and
then you know the apartment villa levels
like war
oh good for you like if you start in a
closet getting burned by cigarettes by
your foster mother you want to be in the
Ville and then you're passed around all
the uncles and then then but getting to
the villa is a [ __ ] good for you
mm-hmm but a lot of people that get to
the villa level and I don't mean real
villa we're talking about fake
apartments Villa
you know mustard-yellow stuck like it
whatever like you know those people are
rule followers they went to stay played
by all the rules and they got nothing
and you can hear it you'll hear it when
you talk to them there's an anger under
their voice there's abiding anger
because they went they got the good
grades and they got into the good school
and they maybe even went to grad school
and they got the internship and they did
the right thing and they just forgot
that they weren't particularly talented
and they didn't particularly matter at
all they weren't unique and they didn't
have any perspective or point of view
that was interesting or important and
they couldn't think outside the box so
they didn't bring anything special to
whatever institution they were working
in and they just basically died on the
vine they were a person they were a
paper-pusher they were just sitting
there everything was about health
insurance I just need to get the right
health insurance because they were
always googling diseases they didn't
have waiting to die I open the season as
a November this is a certain type of
yeah this is a certain type of person
that she's waiting to die they're
waiting to get a terminal illness their
entire life and I just Google and Google
and every job they take is about what
health plan will help when I finally get
this thing I'm convinced I have because
I have a headache sometimes Tuesday
mornings and this is I have aunts like
this I know people like this and they're
not bad people but they're careful
people they've had rules beaten into
their head since they were a little kid
and then you meet really successful
people and they don't give a [ __ ] about
the rules mm-hmm and you wonder you're
like oh there's maybe a correlation here
they're really successful people a lot
of times take now sometimes yes it's
because they were born rich and they
have a lot of money and it's easy to not
care about the rules when your [ __ ]
dad owns [ __ ] you know paramount I
that but then you meet a lot of people
that were successful and got successful
by not giving a [ __ ] that went on the
outside that didn't care that weren't
living every day like they were gonna
die tomorrow don't prepare for your own
death I know that many people out there
like fetishize that they loved it they
loved it they loved telling your stories
about people were [ __ ]
they like car accident lost everything
medical day you know my aunt will do
that she'll go I'm never gonna walk
again a tickle dad
medical dad bankruptcy and then like
invariably you know sometimes I'll meet
some of these people from my town that
like are being talked about and they're
fine yeah I declare bankruptcy I'm fine
like but it's just this horror story
that keeps everyone in line you know and
my aunt would do that she would be a
collection of the tales depressing
stories depressing stories that were
supposed to teach you to follow the
[ __ ] rules and if you didn't somebody
somewhere was gonna kill you you were
gonna die or you were gonna live in
agony and pain who didn't follow the
[ __ ] rules that car is supposed to be
out of here at 7:00 p.m. and it's just
like these are the rule followers and
the rule followers are they're shocked
that they don't get further because
they've done all the things that they
should do they've checked all the boxes
they've dotted the i's they've crossed
the t's and in that process they've
forgotten to bring anything new or
particularly valuable to the table
they just don't the status quo
through-and-through status quo they're
doing the job that a lot of other people
can do they'll even tell you this
sometimes they'll pride themselves on it
like it's a mark of achievement they
feel like a lot of people can do this
job and I'm doing it it's like well no
that's not the move his head but they
love rules and they that's why they love
school
they love college and they love health
care they love having health care and
they loved it and they're like other
people don't they're just like I'm just
waiting to die
they're like I'm just waiting to get in
this car and have a semi wiped me off
the [ __ ] because I just mean while
health care does even cover that by the
way if you do get any of those things
they won't even cover it so it's kind of
a I mean the health care industry is
like it's organized crime like no matter
what kind of health care you have you're
probably [ __ ] there's something really
horrendous happens this episode of the
Tim Dylan show is sponsored by blue Chu
guys remember the days when you were
always ready to go always ready to go
you know before me - I'm kidding
remember the days when you could
adequately perform for your partner
remember those days when your penis got
rock-hard those days when you had a dick
and you had hope and you had the
potential to maybe get a job that didn't
hate and they paid you money
I mean we're gonna move and you're gonna
leave your town and buy a beautiful home
and have a family and you know remember
those days when you thought yet hope
remember those days remember that back
then when you had a hard dick and uh you
were you know you woke up in the morning
you hangover it didn't really bother you
and you could handle your booze remember
those days you could smoke a joint
without thinking about smoking another
one in the middle of the day while you
were at work remember those days
remember those days when you weren't
horribly addicted to heroin remember
those days when you weren't literally
barricading your mother in her [ __ ]
bathroom because she was afraid of you
and you steal her car and go to the city
to try to get some dope remember those
days well we can get you back there you
can go back to those days before you let
the demon that lived inside you take
over before you started sucking dick for
heroin in a supermarket parking lot ok
blue 2 brings you the first chewable
with the same fda-approved ingredients
as Viagra and Cialis you can take them
anytime day or night
even on a full stomach and since they're
chewable they work up to twice as fast
as a pill she can be ready whenever an
opportunity arises whenever an
opportunity arises when somebody wants
to [ __ ] they want a [ __ ] they don't have
time for you to [ __ ] get your life
together start your get your blood
circulating again by going to the gym
and eating right
they want you to choose some blue and
get to business but do you remember
those days remember those days when
you're always ready to go when your
mother and father looked at you and it
wasn't with pure disgust and fear do you
remember those days you remember those
days where the world was your oyster you
can do anything you want you were young
you might have been a bit naive you
remember those days you remember what it
felt like to be a human being and just
enjoy the Sun you remember those days
used to go to the beach with your friend
Karen now she won't talk to you anymore
she won't even answer your calls because
she saw you collecting cans last
Wednesday and it made her shudder she
shut the door of her house because she
saw you peddling a shopping cart full of
cans down the street and you look gaunt
and pale and your eyes are sunken in
your head you remember those days before
that was your reality before the drug
you'd literally take it over your entire
body you remember those days
blue cheese made in the USA and since
blue troop repairs and ships direct
they're cheaper than a pharmacy I mean
how cool is that shipped in discrete
packaging it's very discrete you don't
have to go to the doctor's office or
wait in line at the pharmacy and it
ships right to your door in a discrete
package but do you remember those days
when you're always ready to go you're
ready to [ __ ] when you didn't when you
used to [ __ ] inside remember those days
you [ __ ] outside last week you [ __ ] out
side because nobody would let you use
their bathroom because they knew you're
gonna tie one off in there they knew you
were gonna [ __ ] wrap a balloon around
your arm and sail to the land where
nobody is mad at you they knew what you
were gonna do in that bathroom so you
had to [ __ ] outside to make a point you
shat outside do you remember those days
when you used to [ __ ] inside and you're
always ready to go that hard dick young
hopeful you remember those days that's
blue to calm folks blue2 dot-com promo
code Tim
blue2 dot-com promo code tim t IM use
the code i don't get credit if you don't
use the code blue chew is better cheaper
faster choice so if you want to remember
those days if you want to remember those
days before you scared families in the
mall if you want to remember those days
before parents held their children
tighter before you were a literal
cautionary tale if you want to remember
those days before you considered eating
a cat the other week you thought about
it the only reason you didn't do it
because it would take too much work but
you considered getting a cat braking and
snack skinning it and barbecuing it you
remember those days before you were
doing that blue2 dot-com promo code Tim
thank you but these are the same people
that live in the little villas they live
in the apartments and they peer out and
they and you're like move the [ __ ]
you know thing yeah you see that Toyota
Prius at 7:01 you're like no you know no
cancer you must know some of these
people because you work in the Social
Security office all right absolutely
this [ __ ] the people care about is
insane RINO it's like like you know we
can park there's a reserved parking lot
and that's for people that are grades GS
14 and above but after 2 p.m. you're
allowed to park there I'm like okay
right Park wherever you're walking to
work either way your people that need
cancer like they need the best thing to
happen to them yeah would you - [ __ ]
there live around like to give them some
perspective on life how much of life for
these people is figuring out parking
they're on planet earth for a certain
amount of time so much' life for people
is figuring out that I get my parking
validated am I in the right slip am I
and careful rule following people just
are and God love them you need them but
they're they're always kind of surprised
they didn't go further in life
right actually when they see somebody
that didn't go by the rules gets further
like what you know yeah they're shocked
they're shocked they're shocked that
somebody that went on the outside of the
system figured out a way to crash-land
into something successful you know and I
think a lot of it has to do with how you
raised it because we I was raised by
boomer parents who took they took the
eighteen years of raising me they took
oh they took off they took a vacation
for raising the children as most boomer
parents did I mean they were there but
they weren't there they were and I get a
lot of flack for this from from older
people that message me hey hey
[ __ ] off but the boomer generation in in
a lot of cases was a generation driven
by self-interest greed
self-actualization not in any real way
by the way just constantly trying to
please themselves at the expense of
their children they didn't really care
about their kids this isn't like a new
thing I'm not saying it it was a
generation of fast food stuffing food in
your kid's face you know giving them
activities to do so you didn't have to
raise them you're in dance you're at
sports you're here hey go get molested
at this camp I gotta go and have dinner
with Aunt Sue go get molested and don't
bother me I'm going to dinner with so it
was a group of people with that for the
most part it was about them their
children were about that yes and and and
and and so and you know you would the
food you ate when you grew up it was
poison I mean McDonald's at two you were
being poisoned from the jump with with
these and then I think subsequent
generations maybe over corrected tooth
now were they the helicopter parent and
like the kid but it's better that's
better than the alternative like my dad
mom or like yeah you should go to
college but that was there and
that was the end of their commitment to
it just just suggesting it they they
lightly suggested it a few times like
yeah you should probably go to college
now there are parents that they started
middle school and they and and during
high school they're taking their kids on
college trips and they're going to see
colleges together and they're really
taking an interest in their children my
[ __ ] parents like yeah you should go
to college
I never went and I regret it you should
go then it's not like here's how you do
it we're gonna help you apply
here's your extracurricular activities
my this is a great story about my father
I was standing on the school bus stop up
the block from my house on the corner
there were two schools in my town right
before I got on the bus I was a little
kid it was my first day of school I was
somewhat nervous I said dad which school
am I going to he goes oh I don't know
get on the bus you know that today they
would be arrested right no oh hey get on
the bus what do you want from me I'm
only your guardian I'm only your father
guardian and I know there's two options
and I should know which one the little
kids go through and watch one of the
bigger kids go to but I don't have the
time for that so why don't you just get
on this [ __ ] bus which by the way
could have been taking me too Epstein's
aren't like nobody knew where that bus
was going he didn't even know if it was
to the school I was supposed to go to
he's like just get on the bus and figure
it out son
you know what's the worst thing that
happens you'll get sold in the sex
slavery and we never see again
and we have to [ __ ] have a nice
charity dinner and get a bunch of money
hey this is what's going on here huh but
you know and then you look at like
certain really successful people when
the kids in the womb they're planning
the school that that kids going to right
right you're like they're like oh I know
the kindergarten that this kid's gonna
go to while this kid is in my womb right
it's just every level of commitment
that's how I love my parents
yeah I actually thought about this the
other day because I'm you know last
night I was here and you know there
weren't a lot of older people which is
nice but sometimes you'd go into like
local scenes and there is older and I
love older people but here's what I
don't love is older people that are
I think they have a shot in comedy oh
that that is the proudest I have ever
been of my dad my dad was a musician
when I was younger and he was good he
was like you know you played guitar he
sang he wrote songs he had a band he you
know traveled around but you know when I
was born II had to get serious at length
by the way like many comics don't they
just said oh well we'll raise the kids
in squalor
but he got a job he got a job and and
and and and and and instead of you know
not making money at being a musician he
got a job and he didn't make money at
that you know he was just a bad
salesperson which I appreciate at least
you have the optics of trying sure and
and and he gave it a shot at me and I
had what I I had food and everything
like that you know I clearly but I
didn't have emotional you know you know
but I had the food we had Wendy's I
wanted you know there was some type of
school bus taking you somewhere I was on
a bus going somewhere I had a Monterey
ranch chicken sandwich from Wendy's
there no big deal everything was fine
and but one of the proudest moments I've
ever been in my dad was when he said to
me he started to play music again in
like the local scene in Long Island
where he lives and he did this maybe
this was like four years ago
and he said to me he goes I was playing
out I was going around doing these open
mikes
and then he goes some of the younger
guys were like you're really [ __ ]
good you should do this gig with us like
upstate and he goes okay and it was like
a few hours away from his house and he
goes yeah I just I took a ride with them
we did this gig and then then they were
like you're so good we're planning like
this little door and then he said he
goes what am i insane he's like I'm in
my [ __ ] mid 60's I need to go to Coba
and I was never more proud of him that
when he said that he goes I need to go
home and watch television with my wife I
was so proud of him so proud of him yeah
and I speak for all of it if you're an
older person and you're following your
dream
stop literally if you were an older
person and you are indulging a passion
or following a dream please for the love
of God
stop it because it's over yeah and it's
it's not the move it's not the course I
was so proud of my dad when he's like
what the [ __ ] do I think is gonna have
yeah good for him what do I think is
gonna [ __ ] happen I'm gonna go beyond
the voice can you imagine him telling
his wife like I'm gonna be out of town
for the next couple weeks
yeah boy sure hit the road and the boys
are hitting the road we think we're
gonna do it this time I'm 67 it's time
to get serious it's time to really
buckle down it's like listen guys he had
that time he played the music it was
great you probably [ __ ] some chicks that
were you know good-looking or whatever
whatever whatever you get out of that
you know what I mean you certainly don't
get a windfall of money no but at least
it was good and at the end of the day
you gotta realize it like everybody's
like but Rodney danger
no no no stop using that one example
yeah I'm not saying if you're like if
you're an old person you always wanted
to do stand-up comedy go give it a shot
go try it once don't be sitting
somewhere in an open mic talking to
somebody about how you plan them on
making it let's cut that out cuz there
are older people there's guys in there
52 like you know I don't know how to
play this here's how to play it go home
this is how to play it get in the car
and go to your home go to your villa and
make sure people don't Park past 7:00
p.m. you know the thing that kept you
from doing this for 30 years
that won that thing won the fear that
kept you from doing this by the way a
very rational fear that knew you better
than you did that knew you weren't gonna
make it they kept you [ __ ] married
with kids in a job that rational fear
that keeps people alive one mm-hmm
go acquaint yourself with that fear
again snuggle with it cuddle with it
that fear is not meant to be conquered
this whole thing about conquering fear
has got to go indulge it [ __ ] the fear
literally the fear is what loves you
the fear is what wants you to have a
home and the food this whole thing you
gotta conquer the fear no no no no no no
no no no no no no no the fear is your
friend and that's what people don't
realize the fee
is your friend like I was talking this
guy once he's in his mid-50s he's like I
was just always afraid yeah yes you
should still be afraid I know that fear
follow the fear back to your home
the fear is why you have a home you
weren't gonna make it 30 years ago well
here's what you would have done you
would have ruined your life you would
have been broke and now I know that all
these guys built bar and all these
amazing brilliant comedians and I have a
ton of respect for give people speeches
like follow your dream it's not that bad
to be living on a couch and you know
that that quote yeah a lot of people use
so they don't have to raise your
children that are broke yeah people that
people that use that quote that use that
Bill burr quote as a way to not raise
their kids by the way the like it's not
bad living on a couch when your third
hey shut up in there daddy's doing a
podcast you know it's girl by the way
you say something like that to try to
inspire people then you realize there's
a lot of dirtbags using it as an excuse
to take food out of their children's
mouths absolutely so that they can do
new talent night were they paid to do it
right it's like I feel I feel you know
listen we all get listen you don't want
to tell people you don't ever close the
door behind you like you don't want to
be like we're the last generation of
people to ever do this obviously no one
is saying that there's a lot of people
that are gonna far exceed my success and
career and be better at it and
everything but not when you're 50 you
don't start when you're 50 you just
don't
um also you don't mortgage your
children's future to do this that's
immoral that's a bad you're a bad person
you're a bad person right you're a bad
person for doing that
yeah and it's it's it's very very sad
when that happens yeah Child Protective
Services should come in yeah you're at
open mikes five nights a week
interesting you can't have a child that
is asking you mommy where are you going
or daddy where are you going and you're
going to an unpaid bar show it's immoral
and you have to stop it and you're a bad
person if you're doing that you're not
good I'm not
saying if you have a day job you're
providing for the kids do anything you
want as a hobby do it and by the way
still not this do something else and
make more money for the college fund you
[ __ ] skel you're a skel but I'm not
[ __ ] on how you spend your free time
just I meet certain people they look I'd
better figure it out I got kids it's
like yeah you should have figured it a
long time ago but that's the thing
there's just this idea of like that fear
is always bad and we always have to
conquer it and I don't think so I think
we have to lean into it like and
appreciate it a little bit and
understand that that fear is what's
what's the only reason that you have now
obviously people will say well now
you're contradicting yourself because
the rule-followers are also motivated by
fear untrue the rule file was actually
not motivated by fear they're motivated
by the desire to control which is
different now maybe that's motivated by
fear or whatever if you unpack it but
the rule followers actually people yeah
that are they want control and they
actually want to seem they they just
want to be better than other people they
want to look down on someone even if
it's someone that should just be you
should just pity right they want to look
down on said they look down on the guy
that didn't get health insurance and
then a car hit him they were like well
that wasn't smart was it these poor guys
laying there in a coma and they have to
be like well well CD you see what
happened was you break the rules when
you break the rules is poor guy he's
flatlining
you get t-boned by a bus yeah and these
people they just want to feel a little
better than him that's what it is it's
not so much that rational fear because
they in their minds they should be the
king of the castle they don't realize
the rules they played the game they
played the game yeah so when you meet
people like that you just have to say to
yourself all right I get what you are
there's nothing you know inherently like
evil about you but I know where you are
and I know that you're gonna call the
police if this car is here at 7:05
praise that's what you're built to do
you're built to do that because you
believe if you rat on the guy that
parked his car in the wrong spot then
that means
that that everything is right with the
world are above them you're above them
and that you're gonna move up the ladder
because you think that's how people move
up the ladder by being rats by being
rats and informants and these are the
first people by the way the inner
tyrannical government would inform on
their neighbors and get them dragged
away to a reeducation capital if they're
the first people to dime on their
friends and family and have them dragged
away
it's just who they are you know but
that's different than rational fear
rational fears gotta be ringed into
right because rational fear even if you
decide to do something outside of the
box rational fear makes you work hard
I'm afraid I'm doing a podcast right now
in a hotel room in Timonium Maryland
because I don't want to re-release an
old podcast because I have respect for
my families III because I fear that if I
don't do things all the time that are
funny or interesting or good people will
tell me to go [ __ ] myself as they should
as they should you know but there are
people they just have you know no fear
at all and that's and those are the
people that seem insane because children
have no fear children are insane if you
speak to them they believe things that
aren't true they believe in Santa Claus
children are they're insane and if you
don't become an adult like I had
somebody last night asked me sweet woman
but she goes how do I become a feature
and it's like I there is no answer that
I can give you there is no answer that I
can give you there are no answers to
those questions because you either are
going to become a feature which doesn't
matter if you were featuring friend no
one cares but you're either going to
become that or you're not going to
become that and it's either gonna take
you two years or five years or no years
and I have nothing to say about it then
it doesn't it not does it make me a dick
doesn't make I'm that there's no secret
I can share with you that I'm not
there's no investment advice I can give
you what about investment advice that's
what it whenever like a comedian asked
like somebody for
specific advice about a situation which
I do all the time to people like rogue
and people that I respect I'm like what
should I do here but like very vague
general if isochrone how do I lose so
Dickens how do I got people to like me
I want a headline yeah I wanna know how
do I make a million dollars hey how do I
make a million dollars how do I make 1
million dollars it's like hey I don't
know man but I feel like if I gave you
the advice and I really want to give you
it would involve you getting a gun it
would involve you purchasing a weapon to
probably use in yourself because there
are some people in comedy that you meet
and you go if you got it together you
wouldn't do this like if I could tell
you the skills that you needed to get
better at this you would actually if you
were the type of person who would
succeed at this you wouldn't do it and
that's the crazy thing and that's what
people don't want to hear like if you
had any of the dedication or
self-awareness or or or talent or
whatever that was needed you'd be on the
outside doing fine yeah you would take
that drive and channel it somewhere else
yeah you'd be doing something it's a
rare group of people that can did [ __ ]
flick I'm one of them that just [ __ ]
hit the wall everywhere else and come
into this and they're like ok so I can
figure out how to maneuver and navigate
and I can work hard and I can be
dedicated I can do what I need to do but
there's a lot of people that if they had
those skills they would never have done
this in the first place
there's a lot of people here they just
want to get high they want to get high
and go out with their buddies and that's
fine too right but then you can't ask
why you're not you know what you're not
doing well well you're not doing well
should I get [ __ ] up more oh yeah I
don't know go I go watch it Gary
Vaynerchuk maybe pick a motivational
speaker to fill you with nothing
yeah you know pick pick somebody to tell
you why you're not whole do you think
what you're missing do you think that's
why he's so big because it is general
advice like for gosh like how come I'm
not better it's like cuz you gotta be
better like right they gotta be but
cause he the hard truth
of what it is and that he can't tell
people and I understand why but I don't
hate him like when I'd make fun of him
it's because he does ridiculous things
yeah they're funny but I don't like I
have no hatred trim I don't I don't
think he's ruining the world or anything
I think if you for Italy to see dude if
you think the Long Island medium is
talking your daughter you deserve to get
your money stolen right they're hustlers
you deserve to get your money take if
you're in the back of an Italian
restaurant in Long Island and you've
paid $300 to sit there with a bunch of
other meatballs and this woman walks out
and she pretends like she's talking to
your daughter Nicole who died in a
boating accident and you believe that
and it makes you feel better or whatever
if this is a transactional thing you
know you know or maybe you don't know
but I know that you should get robbed
you should have your money taken from
you cuz it'll just go to something else
stupid right you're not gonna invest in
the next thing that becomes uber it's
just gonna go to a fad diet or some cat
no cash down real estate scam or some of
you would buy that miracle spring water
that idiot sells at 2:00 a.m. like
there's nothing that you people won't
open my mother took money and bought
beanie babies you know at McDonald's and
tried to retire on the mic like
collecting them would her money have
been any worse giving it to Gary
Vaynerchuk or the Long Island medium
though now had my mother flip those
beanie babies in a reasonable amount of
time we'd have a little bit more money
but she waited too long she kept waiting
for like well one day there'll be the
price of diamonds it's like no they're
not no it's people are gonna be like who
gives a [ __ ] there'll be the price of
moon rocks eventually I'm like no this
isn't a currency that continues to
appreciate just get rid of them now
unload them now for the love of God you
know after 9/11 it seems a little weird
to be playing with beanie babies no one
really cares
you know we have to come together as a
country remember the largest Diana bear
how [ __ ] dark that was here's the
Princess Diana bear my mother had and
that was like the big one of the big
beanie babies was he commemorative
Princess Diana beanie baby want to talk
about dark you know very but the whole
[ __ ] the whole thing is like yeah
would her money have been better spent
with the Long Island medium or Caravan
or any of these hucksters sure so what
Gary is unable to tell people what he's
unable to tell people because it's not
terra a terribly inspirational message
is you have to look at people and go the
majority of you are not going to derive
any pleasure from what you do from or
from your job it's just not it's not
gonna happen
that's not the way the world is set up
it's not the way the world is set up for
you to I'm not saying you have to be
miserable I'm not saying you have to
hate what you do you shouldn't but the
idea that you're going to be your own
boss and it's gonna be interesting and
exhilarating and exciting and you're
gonna wake up Monday and you're like I
love that it's Monday I'm so excited
it's Monday let's get it let's get it
hustle grunt it's not gonna [ __ ]
happen and if you're looking for that
get ready for whatever comes with that
which is hard drinking or whatever or or
you're watching spikes get driven
through people's hands on the dark web
to come let's get it whatever it is like
understand that what makes most people
happy is their family their friends the
community hobbies which we not rid of
nobody has hobbies anymore like people
just everything they do they try to
monetize like things that are gonna make
you happy or not now there's a specific
group of people that are gonna be
entrepreneurs but I'm not an
entrepreneur I'm a comedian that has to
do it on my own
who's learning about business I'm not an
entrepreneur I don't get off on the
numbers the base I don't get up every
day and I'm like I just where does our
business time what am i analytic
we gotta grow like I don't think I like
to perform and make funny [ __ ] and then
you have to figure out how to have a
career doing that but I don't get hard
at the [ __ ] business like there are a
group of people that just do they're
into it you know entrepreneurs there's a
certain group of people that are gonna
go that direction and be great at it and
and whether they know who Gary Vee is or
not Gary Vee is not making a difference
between you having a business or not
none of these people are none of these
none of these Thai Lopez any of these
people who don't decide whether you have
a business or not they can tell their
ten-point plan that the videos they said
it none of it is gonna met you're either
a person who wants to work if you're out
on a Saturday night and everybody else
is getting drunk around you and having
fun and hanging out and you want to be
working which I never did I was very fun
to be drunk if you want and I wanted to
tell stories and have people laugh at me
but if you want to be building a
business while everyone else is getting
[ __ ] up then you know okay maybe I'm
one of these people if you're at the
beach and you're like getting antsy
and you're like you know I'd rather not
be here I want to be in an office right
now figuring out how to make money I
don't want to be at the beach I'm
getting antsy I don't want to be in a
back yard with my friends having fun I'm
done with that I did that enough of it
and by the way that was what I felt like
when I was 25 and I got into comedy I
was like I've done I've been in enough
backyards and I've been hammered enough
I've gotten drunk enough I've been you
enough bars I've gone out to dinner
enough I gotta do something else now
otherwise I'm gonna have a completely
wasted [ __ ] life right but that was
because I had that internal realization
it wasn't because I watched I Lopez tell
me
and then I [ __ ] spent three grand on
his 10-point plan and he was like and
here's my Ferrari do you have really
ya know you [ __ ] so it doesn't mean
that you're not suited for that but
there's a lot of be like I have friends
and aren't suited my friends are alright
now wanna be in it and they think I'm
crazy and they're probably not wrong
they're not wrong it isn't saying the
people that are like what do you do just
have fun like I have friends that are on
a beach right now that I spoke to that
are on a penis that are like who they
are not trying to light the world on
fire at all they're not trying like they
just want to enjoy their [ __ ] life
that's what people should aspire to is a
kindred but then there's people that are
not I'm not I'm built to like enjoy life
some people aren't built to enjoy life
we're built to like to do things that
that are good or great or whatever we
want to be great at something if you
want to be great at something you're the
baseline will not be enjoyment she's not
gonna be right it's gonna be fulfillment
and it'll you'll never be fulfilling
it's very long-term it's very long-term
and it's a different set of you know
qualifiers the whole thing is different
right right I have friends that just
want to enjoy that's great because as
long as they have like a coconut shrimp
in their mouth and a shot of rum and
somebody's banging his steel drum and
they don't have to work the next day and
there aren't some beat they're good
mm-hmm and you know but Gary Vaynerchuk
can't tell people he can't walk out and
go guys here's the your biggest issue
you're built to enjoy life that's why
you're not succeeding in the way that
you want because when you're around
other people and they love you that's
enough it can't be enough guys it wasn't
enough for a lot of the Carnegie
Rockefeller it wasn't enough for any of
those people it's not enough for me if
Gary Vaynerchuk said it's not enough for
me the love of my wife and kid doesn't
get me off enough I need more but that's
the honest what it is and there's
nothing I don't think there's anything
wrong with it you need the guy that
needs more because civilization has to
go forward right my friends aren't
driving civilization forward no they're
they're driving illegally a car and
they're hammered and they shouldn't even
be driving the car
but they're certainly not driving
civilization forward it's just what it
is you know right right and you're just
either that person who you're not this
whole idea that you're gonna like flip
and sweat and like oh you turn over
newly it's like yeah that every person
innately has that in them
I was always an entertainer and I found
a way to be an entertainer since I was a
little kid right I'm not a business
person I'm not an entrepreneur I'm not a
deal maker I'm not a hustler I'm not a
grinder I'm I'm very hot like I am now I
work very hard at what I do now but I'm
very happy to not hustle like I fight my
own nature right now why I'm able to
hustle is because I genuinely enjoy
making people laugh and I like making
stupid [ __ ] and having fun right I like
doing this even the parts of it I don't
like I can get through to get to the
parts of it that I like but by no
stretch of the imagination
am I like some [ __ ] so you gotta be
honest about what your nature is I'm not
like a business person I would never
like let's say I'd make a lot of money
it is I'm making decent money now I
would never
yeah it's call myself a business person
I've seen your hotel room you're doing
great I mean yeah this is the Holiday
Inn in Timonium but there's no in my
head there's no like oh I'm a business
guy yeah I'm a CEO I'm a Titan I know
comics that are like that good for that
I'm a boss I'm a boss I'm the boss I
don't know I don't want to be I don't
care right I don't want to be I don't
want people working for me I mean I want
I want people that are working for me
that like enjoy what we're doing yeah
but none of its like me being like oh
you better [ __ ] it like yeah that
doesn't come naturally to me I'm a loner
I want to be alone I want to breeze
through the country doing comedy clubs I
don't care I don't want to be in a
writers room I don't want to like I
don't have I would love to having a show
on TV I'd love to do something like that
but like the idea of being in like a
structure and being like I work for
you're like I don't care
well that corporate [ __ ] just doesn't
matter it doesn't mean that that is like
the wrong way to go it's just for me I
don't none of it matter
hey everybody The Bachelor kicked off
this week on ABC and everyone's very
excited and you know me I've never said
a bad word of
The Bachelor I think it's great and I
think we should spend more time not only
watching it but discussing it if you
watch ABC's The Bachelor you should be
listening to a companion podcast it's
what's done you're not getting the most
out of the show otherwise the problem is
most of the companion shows are absolute
[ __ ] the one you should be listening to
is called another bachelor podcast
that's the name another bachelor podcast
these guys are [ __ ] hilarious there
are three sis wife males with a lot of
perspective on what girls are going
through one of the hosts neck really
funny story he's from La Crosse
Wisconsin which funny enough is where
the smiley face killer did a good amount
of work but sadly not to Nick that's why
he's producing podcasts but it'll be
much better fused at the bottom of a
lake anyway Nick was raised by his
grandmother both of his parents were
diagnosed schizophrenic switch is a bad
roll of the dice but he's a good kid if
Nick was a schizophrenic he'd be funnier
anyway I'm kidding I like Nick I met
Nick once another guy on there Dylan
really funny Jewish from Studio City
mom's from Queens dad's a Trump loving
Vietnam vet from the backwoods of
Virginia by the way all they're doing
with this ad is describing how much
better their parents podcast would be
give me the Trump loving Vietnam vet in
the skid shows a child of divorce to
state the obvious and then there's a
producer Pat from Lumbergh Massachusetts
a heroine ravaged land he was raised by
his mother and stepfather Jimmy Dell who
has a contentious relationship with Pats
15 he dyes his hair often every week
these guys take the piss out of one of
the best shows on television The
Bachelor take out the latest episode
breaking down the limo exits and
shocking return of out of brown
subscribe to another Bachelor podcast on
Apple podcast Spotify YouTube or
wherever you list the podcast and get
ready to laugh your dick off
NIC produces this past weekend with Theo
von nick is a good guy Nick has brought
ABS on the show so we're plugging his
bachelor pad cast um I have not listened
to the podcast but I'm going to and Nick
is like funny when you talk to him so
it's probably not the worst bet like if
you listen
The Bachelor it's not the worst you know
what I mean like so if you if you live
if you watch The Bachelor religiously
and like people like these bachelor
companion podcasts I don't know why I
think it's because the Empire is over
and we we're beginning our transition to
AI and humanity as a race has failed and
and and we're just sucking up the last
little bit of resources on the planet
before a stronger more durable
intelligence comes and takes us over
that's what I believe is happening so I
believe that in this weird interim time
the bachelors like fun you know it's
like a fun way to kind of just like
circle the drain as humanity you know so
they're doing this bachelor kick-off
podcast and I guess it's really good you
know Nick's from La Crosse Wisconsin
he's a podcast producer and he's got his
buddies with him he's got Dylan why did
they put into these Jewish really funny
Jewish from Studio City what's that
about mom's from Queens dad's a Trump
loving Vietnam vet so that's why they
sure that's why they've given you the
backstory guys so it's not only that
they're talking about The Bachelor their
comedic perspectives are informed by
these very interesting lives like Nick's
both of his parents were schizophrenic
and he was raised by his grandma so that
makes him hilarious and then Pat's mom's
from Queens or not Pat I'm sorry uh-uh
who else here Dylan's mother's from
Queens so he's a [ __ ] rip this guy's
a rib his dad supports Trump like 65% of
men in the country but so it gives
dealing this unique perspective like
what's it like to be Jewish and live in
Studio City and then Pat is a 50 year
old who god only knows why he's doing
this he's probably on the edge of
killing himself listen to the show so
Pat doesn't kill himself he was raised
by his mother and stepfather
he's 15 he dyed his hair off if v is an
interesting edge it's not an age where
like this is a cute fun thing to do he
thinks this is gonna like become a thing
I don't know hopefully Pat's
independently wealthy I'm skeptical but
it's another Bachelor podcast and you
can get it let's tell you where you can
get it folks cuz you know you don't know
how to [ __ ] you don't know we're
podcaster how do you get a podcast
nowadays how would I even get it if I
wanted to listen so you can subscribe to
it on Apple podcast Spotify YouTube or
wherever you listen to podcast and
you're ready to laugh your dick off
again it's called another Bachelor
podcast another Bachelor podcast with
Nick whose parents are nuts
Dylan who's Jewish and Pat who dyes his
hair and I'll tell you right now it's a
good lineup of people give it a shot if
you're into The Bachelor there's some
women listening to my program seven or
eight if you I'm kidding there's there's
more than that it meant men like The
Bachelor - men are idiots
the point is this if you watch The
Bachelor this is a good thing to check
out thank you very much goodbye so when
did you figure it out like that you
wanted to channel all this into comedy
then why was twenty five and I was 25
and I had to bottom out first which is
another thing Gary Vee I don't know that
Gary Vee may say this to people I think
Gary Vee does oh I'd love to go on his
podcast and kind of talk to him about
this and be and be like because he would
open my eyes up to some things - and
he'd be like if you know he'd be like if
my thing only helps like 20 people that
who's to say they're not gonna start
Disney and laugh I'm like whatever and
I'm like yeah that's right does [ __ ] a
lot of kids but I mean Splash Mountain
is fun so I get it you know Mickey
waffles but I get what he's saying
I had to bottom out I guess he does I
think he does do this I think he does go
on the route of like you're not failing
enough I think a lot of these guys do
that tell people they're not failing
enough well that's a good way to have
people buy into like I fail all the time
yeah I'm on the right great but I think
what you gotta tell people is just like
kind of got a bottom out or you gotta
hit a wall and then you got like I hit a
wall when I was 25 years old I hit a
wall where I was drinking every night I
was working at a job that really no
longer exists
I was trying to sell select mortgages in
2009 after the financial crisis like
post crisis I was trying to sell more
it's insane right it made no sense and I
was with a group of people who were we
were all sitting in an office
it was decrepid and there were fruit
flies and leaks from the ceiling and it
was a windowless office in Long Island a
broad hollow road and all of the
mortgage guys had left like it was like
life after people like essentially like
it was like almost tumbleweeds blowing
through the parking lot because all the
Porsches and Maseratis and BMWs they'd
all either been repossessed or they
drove them somewhere else you know these
people were all gone and it was like my
friend's old Chevy and like me with my
suburban that I couldn't afford to put
gas in and I was in the bad job and I
was drinking a lot and then I got a
summons to be a juror on on a on a trial
am i looked at the summons and I was
like okay this might be interesting I
knew immediately that it might be like a
weirdly pivotal event I can't explain
how I just looked at the thing and I'm
like this might be [ __ ] weird and I
got to the courthouse and my friend by
the way my friend Ryan who I love to
death was driving me to the thing and we
both had no do right we were
directionless 25 years old long island
directions which meant we're having a
great time we're having a great time
being white interaction listen Long
Island it's fun
smoking weed booze him eating in a
corporate steakhouse whenever we wanted
he would steal money from his parents
and just we would go I would steal like
we're thieves would just take things
Garrus you don't need it it's mine now
and not even like we're heroin addicts
like he would just take a hundred
dollars off the mantle and we'd go over
a ribeye with his mother would be like I
left a hundred on the man or we'd be
like why and I would just have whatever
money that I had because I was my I had
bought a house when I was 22 over
everybody that's listen to the show
knows this a lot of people know this but
I had stopped making mortgage payments
because not on
couldn't I make them but it didn't even
make sense
how's it look 50% of its value in the
last two years so it would be crazy to
keep making them but so here's the deal
right I'm living rent-free so I'm not
making mortgage payments so I'm living
rent-free my buddy so we're just we're
just eating in Vince's clam bar things
are okay and and I don't mean okay I
mean we're all life is beating the [ __ ]
out of us but you'd never know you'd
never know we just and that's why I
think I was able to do comedy because
like for a while when comedies throwing
dirt in your face you have to just kind
of walk around like a good Howard thinks
they're good they're good oh this dirt
oh nothing I love dirt I'm sleeping in a
[ __ ] you know in a garbage pile as it
bit but we when he dropped me off he
goes good luck it was the craziest thing
because he knew I wanted to get jury
duty because I'm like I was like I think
this might be fun to do he's like yeah
dude because again you have to
understand what being directionless
means we had no direction we didn't know
where we were got nobody knew which way
we were going so like the idea of jury
duty said this is new most people dread
it they want to get out of it we're like
uh could be fun new experience could be
fun I show up and I see like there's
news vans outside of the courthouse yes
I'm like this is interesting I thought
it's gonna be like some guy like the
Long Island jury duty is usually like
some old Jewish woman fella no Wendy's
she wants a hundred and fifty K Wendy's
wants to give her 80 because she was
drunk
something like that to give and take
something in that realm of you know I
get there and they're like this is a
trial for murder torture rape
immediately I'm excited I'm excited
immediately because you're like they're
this number one cool like let's be very
honest cool it's a cool thing that
someone was murdered and tortured and
been raped
but by the way they got a conviction of
right allegedly right allegedly but
here's what's cool about it here's
what's cool but not that it happened not
that it happened what's cool about it is
I get to now go undercover and figure it
all out I'm the detective now if I get
selected so I walked in and I I found
out later that I was a deflected defense
pick like the defense wanted me which
means they looked at me and were like
he'll understand torture
that's literally hell he's probably done
it yeah no they look at me in they're
like look at that guy's face he
understands extenuating circumstances he
gets that sometimes things need to be
done and they weren't wrong at that
point in my life I was a 25 year old
degenerate alcoholic with a foreclosed
house Long Island I knew that sometimes
you had to carve a [ __ ] up I was in the
closet I hadn't come out of the closet
yet I was still occasionally trying to
date like Long Island women like like
yeah like like that were men I mean Long
Island women wore a certain level of
long I'm an Italian woman is a dude it's
like literally a guy it just becomes a
guy like go from like here to like here
it's like God but so I was like I was so
I knew going in I'm like my license and
this is how great Long Island is my
license is currently suspended
it's like currently suspended it's been
suspended like over 20 times I legally
couldn't even drive to the court that's
why I had my friend drop me off because
I'm like I can't get pulled over driving
to the court so I'm a criminal who's
coming in for jury duty to decide the
fate of something inside the faith of
this of this guy and so they say to me
so I'm like I got number one I can't
look too eager because then they're not
gonna want me so I got letting by the
way this is advice to any of you that
maybe want jury duty this is advice as
to how to get it and only get it if it's
something good like torture you know
sure jury duty you can't look too eager
you have to roll your eyes you have to
like [ __ ] I can't believe this whatever
so that the prosecutor said to me she
goes mr. Dhillon your license has been
suspended a bunch I'm sure you hate the
police you don't like them and I said no
I hate myself for being irresponsible
not paying those tickets Wow boom
great answer she sits down the defense
attorney gets up this lady who wore like
you know miss Frizzle and the Magic
School Bus she wore those outfits and
crazy jewelry and later someone said
that's to distract the jury and I was
like that's kind of brilliant like
sometimes like she's like we're like
that she just wears crazy [ __ ] to court
mm-hmm because like they said one lawyer
back.all it's going to get so smokin
courtrooms which smoke a cigar and he
had a wire going to the ash never fell
off so the jury would look at his cigar
and to be smoking it down wondering when
ash was gonna fall off right and [ __ ]
they wouldn't hear anything the other
guy said so it's like this is brilliant
so maybe this [ __ ] he's doing this on
purpose because she's dressed like a
literal clown right she gets up she's
like mr. Dhillon murder torture rape how
can you be impartial when you hear words
like this and I was like because and she
gave me a pretty easy one cuz she wanted
me I think that's a pitcher but I was
like ah they're just words they're
literally just worth I've not seen one
shred of evidence there are only words
and I was like words mean nothing and
she was like oh good and I knew her when
I said words mean nothing I knew I'm
like oh he probably threatened his [ __ ]
a million times and she's gonna love
that
I said words mean nothing because the
defense is gonna be like oh great
if he believes words mean nothing he's
gonna be able to excuse all of these
threats all of these verbal assaults
that have been documented by countless
witnesses yeah when you're saying this
stuff is it like having a good set do
you know you're like damn I'm crushing
yeah I knew I'm do I know I'm doing good
and I know I need to get this and I
don't know why yeah this is what garyvee
can't tell you guys you can't be like
wait till someone's tortured get on jury
duty like this is how I had you know
show you
these moments in life organically you
can't plan them out you don't get them
if ty Lopez tells you to now I'm not
saying you have to get them through a
murder torture rape trial but there's
worse ways to do it and it certainly
helps it certainly helps um you know and
then I was old and up with my friend
picked me up he's like I was like I got
it man he's like I knew you would was
like an addition anything I knew you
would do that trial was just his
two-week intense week and a half
intense like rah meditation on mortality
like the idea that every day you were
hearing about somebody whose life was
taken and somebody whose life we
convicted him life plus 50 years no
parole because he was literally guilty
so I mean really guilty you know I don't
I don't really know I didn't listen that
much but it seemed bad he had weird eyes
no he was seriously I listened to
everything I was into it he was he was
so guilty I thought the next I thought
the next thing was gonna be like and and
now here's the YouTube clip of the crime
like that's how bad it was but during
this whole thing I was I was like
looking at the the a DA who's now like
the DA or the Congress where I forgot
what she is now but she was really good
at her job so good at her [ __ ] job
that you know you were like this is
exactly what she's meant to do she's
meant to do this you know she was had a
Special Victims Unit and I was like I'm
not meant to sell mortgages in a strip
mall in long night like I'm just not
meant to be it was it's not a strip mall
is an office building whatever I was
like I got a not do that you know I got
to figure out a way not to do that and I
think I started comedy in that was in
the spring that trial and I started
comedy in the fall late August mm-hmm
late August and I had one more summer of
drinking in me at one more summer still
didn't get it had to like my friend's
father me had that get into boating
accidents that summer I mean I still was
being beaten in a mad but by the time by
the time that summer right the rape
trial wasn't enough
I mean that's what this guy was a cool
guy who's so cool when you get the two
boating accidents with someone they're
fun to get back on a boat with someone
you got into an accident with means they
they're fun um but at the end of that I
was like okay it's time to change
because sometimes you just got to get
something out of your system you got to
get being a loser out of your system
right I being a loser is fun no one will
admit like that being a loser has its
benefits and and actually starting to
not be losers is can suck and then you
have to worry about like look now I got
a stay not a loser right right obviously
you don't want to be a loser but like
and then people people would look back
oh you would never lose I'm like yeah I
was I was an absolute like ever I had
lost everything and I was like I was the
definition of lose like right but
sometimes you just got to get that [ __ ]
out of your system before you can go and
some unfortunately sometimes that kills
you right sometimes that kills you
sometimes the things you have to do to
get being a loser out of your system
kill you so it's unfortunate and then
sometimes you'll never get being a loser
out of your system which is why you need
to get killed in Iran you need to get
shot in Iran sometimes it will never
work
it's you're never gonna see the light so
you just need to go to Iran and get shot
and it's not this is nothing negative
about you it's just an observation I
have from 30,000 feet looking at your
life and I'm going you need to be a flag
on a mantel that someone points to that
is your moment
that's your pivot and they point to it
with pride I would give garyvee all of
my money if he started his next lecture
by grabbing the mic and going half of
you in this room need to be in Iran
getting shot at right now you need to be
getting shot at in Tehran right now and
10% of you should have your own
companies all right thank you guys for
listening I really appreciate it thank
you for coming on yeah you think you're
the best Josh plug your social media if
anyone's around Baltimore do you
showered is umar run that show my runs
his show gin and jokes at Joe squared
and Baltimore the first Thursday of
every month Matt Josh could earn on all
it's a great show and he gets some
really funny comics yeah it's a great
show Matt Josh get dirt on all social
media stuff and Omar and I have a
podcast called the digression session so
check that out well thank you so much
thank you the best thanks a lot buddy